teasé le col de la vessie et donc c'est
vraiment l'entrée dans la prostate avec
à partir de ce point là la prostate la
prostate
objet de toutes les attentions à
l'hôpital des franciscaines de
versailles avec cette reproduction
géante les spécialistes sensibilise la
prostate est un organe qui se situe en
aval de la vessie dans le périnée ou
disons dans le dans le petit bassin des
hommes exclusivement des hommes et qui a
pour rôle de servir à la fois à produire
une partie du liquide séminal est à la
fois de servir en quelque sorte
d'aiguillage entre la voie urinaire et
la voix séminal un organe qui évolue
avec l'âge les symptômes apparaissent à
partir de 50 aux deux maladies sont
fréquentes
la dénommée le cancer la prostate évolue
au cours de la vie d'un homme lorsqu'il
était plus jeune elle a tendance à être
plus petit et puis au fur et à mesure de
la vie elle va grossir progressivement
cette croissance s'accompagne de
l'apparition de symptômes plus ou moins
gênantes
un dépistage est recommandé à partir de
50 ans chaque année environ 100 mille
nouveaux patients présentent des
symptômes d'adénome près de 2 millions
d'hommes souffrent d'une maladie bénigne